Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在我们深入今天的节目之前，我想快速通知大家一件目前正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Get ready as we dive into the fascinating world of psychology with a Celtic twist. We are
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人直接送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的专属链接参加挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士一对一辅导一小时的机会。想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。准备好，我们将带着凯尔特风情，一起深入探索迷人的心理学世界。我们将
going on a cross-country road trip as we compare and contrast how Ireland and the UK train and qualify their counselling psychologists. But that's not all. We're also spilling the Barry's tea on how you can or cannot travel and work internationally once you're a qualified psychologist. So grab your favourite cuppa, stay tuned and I hope you find this really useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. My name is Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for choosing me to help you learn more about the world of psychology and mental health. Do please come along and download my free guide for the DeclinSci, which is a doctorate in clinical psychology, which also includes lots of useful tips and guidance
进行一次跨国公路旅行，对比爱尔兰和英国培训及认证心理咨询师的不同之处。但不仅如此。我们还将八卦一些内幕，探讨当你成为一名合格的心理学家后，如何（或能否）在国际上旅行和工作。所以，请端起你最喜欢的茶，锁定频道，希望你会觉得这非常有用。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。非常感谢你选择我来帮助你更多地了解心理学和心理健康的世界。请务必前来下载我的免费指南，关于临床心理学博士学位（DeclinSci），其中还包含许多有用的建议和指导
for anyone embarking on professional psychology applications. You can do that by coming along to my website www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk and then check out the free resources option. You can also click any of the links in my show notes or any of the links in my social media. Come and follow me everywhere I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. Let's dive in and meet our guest for today. Hi, I just want to welcome our guest for today, Dr. Leora de Flumery. Hi. Hi, it's so good to be here this morning. How are you, Marianne? I'm really well, thank you. So thank you for connecting with me. We connected on Instagram
任何准备从事专业心理学申请的人都可以参考。你可以通过访问我的网站 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk 来做到这一点，然后查看免费资源选项。你也可以点击我的节目说明中的任何链接，或者我社交媒体中的任何链接。来到处关注我吧，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。让我们开始吧，见见我们今天的嘉宾。嗨，我只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾，利奥拉·德·弗卢默里（Leora de Flumery）博士。嗨。嗨，今天早上能来这里太好了。你好，玛丽安？我很好，谢谢。谢谢你与我联系。我们是通过 Instagram 联系的
this time, didn't we? And we got to chatting in the DMs about whether a podcast episode might be really interesting. And I think it will be. So we're going to be talking about kind of all things today, but qualifying and training in Ireland, living and working in Ireland. But also, I think you said originally that you were born in America and then moved over from the States to Ireland. So we're going to kind of talk about that and we're going to talk about individual differences between what we think might be the Irish programme for counselling psychology and the UK programme. And I thought it was about time we did an episode with someone based in Ireland who is working there because actually my second biggest audience for the podcast is in Ireland so delighted to have you here. I'm delighted to be here and I'm not surprised that it's the second largest audience there is so much overlap between people who are qualifying in Ireland and
这次是吧？我们在私信里聊起了做一期播客节目会不会非常有趣。我想会的。所以我们今天将讨论各种事情，但在爱尔兰获得资格认证和培训、在爱尔兰生活和工作。而且，我想你最初说过你出生在美国，然后从美国搬到了爱尔兰？所以我们要谈谈这个，还要谈谈我们认为的爱尔兰心理咨询硕士/博士项目与英国项目之间的个别差异。我觉得是时候邀请一位在爱尔兰定居并在那里工作的嘉宾来做一期节目了，因为实际上我的播客的第二大听众群体就在爱尔兰，所以很高兴你能来到这里。我也很高兴来到这里，而且我对这里是第二大听众群体并不感到惊讶，因为在爱尔兰获得资格的人和
UK we go back and forth a fair bit. Yeah good well one of the first differences I've noticed already is that you mentioned in our pre-chat about the HSE. Could you tell us a little bit about the HSE and how that differs from the NHS, if indeed it does? Great question. So I am not an expert, I suppose, in the HSE. I work in private practice at the moment. I did complete my placements during my training, primarily within the HSC, actually all within the HSC. So my placements were in adult mental health, in primary care for children, adolescents, families, all that stuff, and also some assessment work in there.
英国之间有很多重叠，我们经常两边跑。是的，好的。我注意到的第一个不同之处是，你在我们之前的聊天中提到了 HSE（爱尔兰健康服务署）。你能跟我们简单讲讲 HSE，以及它与 NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）有什么不同吗（如果确实有不同的话）？这是个好问题。所以，我想我并不是 HSE 的专家。我目前在私人诊所工作。我在培训期间确实完成了实习，主要是在 HSC，实际上全都是在 HSC。所以我的实习是在成人心理健康、儿童、青少年和家庭初级保健，所有这些，还有一些评估工作。
And then my third year placement was in psycho-oncology in a HSC hospital. The reason why I paused there is because it wasn't kind of your typical psychologist training and practicum or placement opportunity but it wasn't a hsc hospital so it was more acute hospital treatment setting um so the difference is i have not worked in the nhs i do not know a whole lot about it in the hsc i just have my placement experiences so the hsc is it takes an mdt approach i'll just outline kind of what i'm aware of about the hsc and you let me know where the differences are i suppose we take an mbt approach and it is psychiatrist-led and that's slowly changing where psychologists are taking on a little bit more leadership within each team every team is going
然后我的第三年实习是在 HSE 医院的心理肿瘤学部门。我之所以停顿一下，是因为它不像那种典型的心理学家培训和实习机会，但它是一家 HSE 医院，所以它更像是一个急性医院治疗环境，嗯……所以不同之处在于，我没有在 NHS 工作过，我对它了解不多。在 HSC，我只有我的实习经验。所以 HSC 采取的是多学科团队（MDT）方法，我先大致勾勒一下我对 HSC 的了解，然后你告诉我有什么不同。我想我们采用的是多学科方法，并且是由精神科医生主导的，这种情况正在慢慢改变，心理学家在每个团队中承担更多的领导角色。每个团队都会
to have an occupational therapist um it's going to have an SLT, it's going to have all those people in the allied health services that are working together under the leadership of a psychiatrist. Is it psychiatrist led within the NHS typically or do psychologists lead psychological teams? I've wondered that. It tends to be so it's it has traditionally been that way but it is changing and there are some psychology-led teams or even even nurse-led teams you know so but generally speaking in the most part certainly in inpatient units I would say in the most part it's still psychiatry-led but not exclusively. Yeah so I'm trying to think about other potential differences that there might be the differences for for the people who are going to be listening
配备一名职业治疗师，嗯……会配备一名语言治疗师（SLT），会有所有这些专职医疗服务人员在精神科医生的领导下协同工作。在 NHS 中，通常是由精神科医生主导，还是由心理学家领导心理团队？我一直很好奇这一点。通常是这样的——传统上一直是这样的，但它正在改变，也有一些由心理学家领导的团队，甚至还有由护士领导的团队，你知道的。但总的来说，在绝大多数情况下，我可以说在住院部，主要仍然是由精神科医生主导的，但并非绝对。是的，所以我在想可能存在的其他差异，对于收听
to this podcast I suppose would be that recently counselling psychologists have received funding from the HSE so that means that you're paid a salary as you would be for clinical psychology training programs but in both the UK and in Ireland. Basically, what that means is that you are supposed to work for the HSE as a counselling psychologist and as a clinical psychologist in those first couple of years post-qualification, which I believe is the same in the UK, but there is kind of an expectation that you might work within a public health service. There isn't actually. So when you do your training in clinical psychology, they're offering you a fixed term period of employment as a trainee clinical psychologist. But there's no prerequisite
这个播客的听众来说，差异可能在于，最近心理咨询心理学家已经获得了 HSE 的资助，这意味着你会获得薪水，就像英国和爱尔兰的临床心理学培训项目一样。基本上，这意味着你作为一名心理咨询心理学家和临床心理学家，在获得资格后的头几年里应该为 HSE 工作，我相信英国也是如此，但人们确实有一种期望，即你可能会在公共卫生服务部门工作。实际上并没有。因此，当你攻读临床心理学培训时，他们会为你提供一份作为临床心理学家实习生的定期雇佣合同。但这并不是一个先决条件
that you must work in the NHS post qualification. Obviously, they are hoping you will. But certainly in my case, when I qualified qualified in 2011 there were no jobs available and so I was unemployed for a period of time and so whilst that has changed now and now usually people are getting jobs even when they're in their last year of training um you know it was it's bleak times and it was like I did do a little bit of kind of you know research work and stuff for myself but you know I was fortunate I was able to get an NHS role but there's no you're not you're not contracted to say that I will work for this period of time I wonder if that might change ultimately because as private practice
你必须在获得资格后在 NHS 工作。显然，他们希望你这样做。但就我而言，当我于 2011 年获得资格时，没有工作岗位，所以我失业了一段时间。因此，虽然现在情况已经改变了，现在通常人们甚至在培训的最后一年就能找到工作，嗯，你知道的，那段时期很暗淡，就像我确实为自己做了一点研究工作之类的，但你知道的，我很幸运能够找到一份 NHS 的角色，不过没有合同规定我必须为这段时间工作。我不知道最终这是否会改变，因为随着私人诊所
becomes more and more popular and more and more viable and people think about the work-life balance that's perhaps afforded from doing that I wonder if that will change but currently that's not the case so in ireland there there would be kind of the expectation for clinical psychology um clinical psychologists once you complete your program that you would be working for the hsc for a little bit um i don't again i'm not a clinical psychologist, so I haven't looked at the contracts. I don't know whether that's pressure that people kind of fall into and people don't want to, people don't want to step on toes or whether it is actually contractually obligated. Cancelling psychology trainees have only received funding in the past six months to a year. Prior to
变得越来越受欢迎，越来越可行，人们开始考虑通过这种方式可能带来的工作与生活平衡，我不知道这是否会改变，但目前并非如此。因此在爱尔兰，对于临床心理学，临床心理学家在完成项目后，会有这样的期望：你会在 HSE 工作一段时间。我再次申明，我不是临床心理学家，所以我没有看过合同。我不知道这是一种人们顺从的压力，人们不想踩到别人的脚趾，还是真的是合同规定的义务。心理咨询实习生在过去六个月到一年内才获得资助。在此之前，
that, it was entirely self-funded doctoral programs and it was like in the UK incredibly competitive to get into these training programs um we're talking I think that the numbers were there were 480 applicants the year that I applied to about 45 to 50 slots available around the country um in clinical training programs. For the counseling training program, I think that it was 150 applicants for my cohort, which took in 14. So again, it's similarly competitive. There are similar expectations to my understanding of working in relevant settings beforehand. And then you're put on this three-year professional doctoral training program within the counseling doctoral program and you're expected to
这是完全自费的博士项目，就像英国一样，竞争非常激烈，难以进入这些培训项目。嗯，我们说的是，我申请的那一年有 480 名申请者，全国大约有 45 到 50 个临床培训项目的名额。对于心理咨询培训项目，我认为我的那一届有 150 名申请者，招收了 14 人。所以同样，竞争非常激烈。据我了解，对事先在相关领域工作的期望也是相似的。然后你会被安排在心理咨询博士项目内进行为期三年的专业博士培训项目，你被期望
do a research phd level piece of research um so you're held to like the proper viva it's not that you're doing a doctoral service project you're doing a full dissertation which would be a difference I suppose between the counselling psychology doctorate and the clinical psychology doctorate to my understanding here I hope that answers some questions at least there are lots of differences yeah I mean the one that will be very exciting for our listeners if they're based in the UK is the idea that actually you guys have managed to secure paid funding for counselling so I'd imagine that the rates of applicants will go up considerably now in Ireland for counselling because I don't know why this has
做一个研究，达到博士水平的研究。所以你要通过正规的论文答辩（viva），而不是做一个博士服务项目，你要做一篇完整的论文，据我理解，这大概就是爱尔兰这里的心理咨询博士学位和临床心理学博士学位之间的区别。希望这至少能回答一些问题，确实有很多不同之处。是的，我的意思是，如果我们的听众在英国，会让他们非常激动的一点是，你们实际上已经成功为心理咨询争取到了带薪资助，所以我可以想象，现在在爱尔兰，心理咨询的申请者比例会大幅上升，因为我不知道为什么这在英国一直
perpetuated in the UK it doesn't seem For me, they're often advertising qualified band seven clinical or counselling psychologists. You know, they're essentially saying, it's fine. You know, you can do the same job. So why the inequity? It's not right. To my understanding, so there's been a lot of work behind the scenes here in Ireland to secure that funding for the past, honestly, 15, 20 years going on. To my understanding, there is an understanding within the healthcare providers that our trainings are so comparable. You and I were even discussing in our pre-chat there that in Ireland, it sounds like counselling psychologists receive even more similar training to clinical psychologists than counselling psychologists would in the UK, where we receive placement opportunities from childhood all the
延续下来，似乎并非如此。对我来说，他们经常招聘合格的七级临床或心理咨询心理学家。你知道的，他们基本上是在说，没关系。你知道的，你可以做同样的工作。那为什么会有不平等呢？这不对。据我了解，过去老实说有 15、20 年的时间，爱尔兰这里幕后做了很多工作来争取这笔资金。据我了解，医疗服务提供者内部有一种共识，即我们的培训非常具有可比性。你和我甚至在我们之前的聊天中讨论过，在爱尔兰，听起来心理咨询心理学家受到的培训与临床心理学的培训甚至比英国的心理咨询心理学家更相似，在英国，我们获得的实习机会从儿童时期一直延伸到
way up through adulthood. We're encouraged to take on older adult placements. We have a multitude of placements. Some people do ID placements. You really receive comparable training. But from my understanding, it's that HR hasn't really understood that the two programs are similar um genuinely like I've heard that there is just this little this delay in being oh wait do you have a lack of qualified providers who can actually help people with their mental health and we have this entirely untapped group of psychologists who are coming out every year um we only got that funding recently so that means that many of us would go into more private sector work um if you did qualify before this group
成年。我们被鼓励参加老年人实习。我们有多种实习机会。有些人做智力障碍（ID）实习。你确实受到了具有可比性的培训。但据我所知，人力资源部门并没有真正理解这两个项目是相似的。嗯，老实说，我听说只是有这样一个小小的延迟，即“哦，等等，你们是不是缺乏合格的医疗人员来真正帮助人们解决心理健康问题？而我们有一群每年都在毕业的、完全未被开发的心理学家群体……”我们是不久前才获得这笔资金的，这意味着如果我们在这个群体和刚刚开始的这一届之前获得资格，我们中的许多人会进入更多的私营部门工作。
and this cohort that's just starting in now um that being said many counselling psychologists work in the public health service of my friends the majority are working in the HSE a couple are working in the Irish prison service there's incredible work happening in the Irish prison service that counselling psychologists are specifically well suited to perform in my opinion but also a lot of people in private work like myself it's just really interesting it's really useful and it almost seems like Ireland get it more than you know than than the UK do at the moment so I think you know certainly some of the work that my one of my colleagues Dr Tara Quincharillo is doing she's absolutely demonstrating her capabilities as a qualified counselling psychologist she does lots of work in the media but I think even in our disciplines as a clinical psychologist it's only really in the last few
话虽如此，许多心理咨询心理学家在公共卫生服务部门工作，我的朋友大多数在 HSE 工作，还有几人在爱尔兰监狱服务部门工作。爱尔兰监狱服务部门正在开展令人难以置信的工作，依我之见，心理咨询心理学家非常适合在其中发挥作用，但也有很多人从事私人工作，就像我一样。这真的很有趣，非常有用，而且看起来爱尔兰似乎比英国目前更能理解这一点。所以我认为，当然我的一位同事塔拉·昆查里洛博士（Dr. Tara Quincharillo）正在做的一些工作，她绝对展示了她作为一名合格的心理咨询心理学家的能力，她在媒体上做了很多工作，但我认为即使在我们的学科中，作为一个临床心理学家，也只是在过去几年里我们才意识到它们有多么相似。
years we've realised how similar they are yeah can I ask what might feel like quite a naive question so in the NHS you know you in essence get free at the point of delivery healthcare from cradle to grave is that the same with the Hse that's the promise is it the delivery i don't know um yeah so there's not so it's fun it's funded by taxpayers in the same way as the nhs is it yes there you you have access in terms of mental health care you have access to public mental health care your whole life that being said waiting lists are very, very tricky and very long comparably. I think in Wexford, so I'm in Wicklow, which is just south of Dublin, Wexford is just the county south of that. Wexford had very, very long waiting lists last year. I think that we're talking like 18 month
是的，我可以问一个听起来可能相当幼稚的问题吗？所以在 NHS 中，从摇篮到坟墓，你基本上可以获得免费的医疗保健。HSE 也是如此吗？承诺是这样的，但实际交付是怎样的呢？我不知道。嗯，是的，所以它不是……它是通过纳税人资助的，就像 NHS 一样，是的。你在心理健康护理方面拥有终身获得公共心理健康护理的权利。话虽如此，等待名单非常非常棘手，而且相比之下非常长。我想在韦克斯福德（Wexford），所以我住在威克洛（Wicklow），就在都柏林的正南方，韦克斯福德就是它南边的那个郡。去年韦克斯福德有非常非常长的等待名单。我想我们谈论的是
to two year waiting lists for child mental health service. and obviously people do age out then and it gets quite tricky um in terms of assessments in terms of assessment of needs does somebody need to go for specific assessments it gets really tricky quite quickly so yes that's the promise okay and is hse only mental health care or do they do broken legs and i don't know it's everything it's everything and hSE is the health body for everything um so it's mental health care it's physical health care it's cancer care it's it's everything yeah but you also can opt into the private sector you can opt into the private sector for all of those services as well which is the same in the UK yes absolutely thank you um
儿童心理健康服务有 18 个月到两年的等待名单。显然，人们随着时间长大超龄了，情况就会变得相当棘手。在评估方面，在需求评估方面，某人是否需要去进行特定的评估，这很快就会变得非常棘手。所以，是的，承诺是这样的。好的，HSE 仅提供心理健康护理，还是也处理骨折之类的问题？我不知道。是一切，是一切。HSE 是负责一切的健康机构，所以它是心理健康护理、身体健康护理、癌症护理，它是一切。是的，但你也可以选择加入私营部门，你也可以为所有这些服务选择加入私营部门，英国也是如此。是的，绝对的。谢谢，嗯，
just uh in case our listeners obviously we're in ireland you absolutely get yes but you know i think part of my role as you know a mental health and psychology advocate is to help illuminate what's happening just over that small patch of water um and you know it i find it baffling really with, with Northern Ireland. Like literally you could be living next door to someone that is seen by the NHS or is training in the NHS and you're with the HSE. I find that bonkers. It's wild.
只是为了以防我们的听众，显然我们在爱尔兰，你绝对会得到，是的。但你知道，我认为我的角色的一部分，正如你所知，作为一个心理健康和心理学的倡导者，是帮助阐明那小片水域对面正在发生的事情。而且你知道，我对北爱尔兰的情况感到非常困惑。字面上看，你可能和一个由 NHS 看诊或在 NHS 接受培训的人住在隔壁，而你却在 HSE。我觉得这太疯狂了。太疯狂了。
It is, it is. I've heard it's easier to access treatment in the NHS. There are, I'm thinking back to people in my master's so prior to my doctoral training two people from my master's are currently training at oxford um in the clinical psychology doctoral program there are lots of people who choose to go the uk route just because there are so many more universities that do offer uh clinical training programs and counseling psychology doctoral programs um so i very much understand that do offer clinical training programmes and counselling, psychology, doctoral programmes. So I very much understand that.
确实是，确实是。我听说在 NHS 更容易获得治疗。我在想我的硕士同学——在我的博士培训之前，我硕士班的两个人目前正在牛津大学攻读临床心理学博士项目。很多人选择英国路线，只是因为有更多的大学提供临床培训项目和心理咨询心理学博士项目，所以我非常理解这一点。
Over here in Ireland, we're a much smaller country. We're much smaller. We're 5 million people. That's it. I was over in Galway for the Irish Psychological Society conference in September and I absolutely loved it. And I loved that it felt so much smaller and everyone was so friendly I felt like I was a natural natural born Irish woman like everyone
在爱尔兰这边，我们是一个小得多的国家。我们小得多。我们有 500 万人口。就是这样。今年 9 月我在戈尔韦（Galway）参加爱尔兰心理学会（PSI）会议，我非常喜欢它。我喜欢那种规模小得多的感觉，每个人都那么友好，我觉得自己就像一个天生爱尔兰女性，因为每个人
was so friendly and chatty and I was like these are my people like you know it's it's one of the it's one of the perks of being in a smaller country is that we are a smaller network so you know people who are working just over the border in Wexford you know people who are working for Jigsaw which is our young people's mental health service that makes it even easier for people 18 to 26 to access care you know people who are working in all of these different services it's very easy to kind of find your feet here in Ireland and to come at home professionally, to be honest. So with the whole Brexit situation, has it made it trickier for people in Ireland to come over to the UK or is that still as easy or straightforward as it ever was? As easy as it ever was and will continue to be indefinitely british universities to my
都那么友好健谈，我觉得“这些人就是我的人”，你知道的。这是身处一个小国家的福利之一，我们是一个更小的网络，所以你知道在边境那边的韦克斯福德工作的人，你知道为 Jigsaw（我们的年轻人心理健康服务机构，让 18 到 26 岁的人更容易获得护理）工作的人，你知道在所有这些不同服务中工作的人，在爱尔兰这里很容易找到方向，老实说，在专业上找到归属感。那么，随着英国脱欧（Brexit）的整个局势，爱尔兰人去英国是否变得更加棘手，还是像以前一样容易或直接？像以前一样容易，并且将无限期地继续下去。据我理解，英国大学
understanding are treating irish applicants as though they're applying from within the uk um so that means that you qualify for if you're going to a program that's fee paying um you qualify for in uk fees which is great um i'm not sure because I don't know personally, I haven't actually asked people about kind of whether they're able to take on the role of trainee clinical psychologist. I assume you are, if you are Irish, because if you're Irish, you're allowed to work in the UK with no work permit. And that would probably meet the threshold then for you to be able to get paid by the NHS. Yeah. OK. Yeah. All right. So there really is. And there's also British Psychological Society also basically says if you're targeted with the PSI,
将爱尔兰申请者视同为从英国境内申请，这意味着如果你去一个收费的项目，你符合支付英国国内学费的资格，这太棒了。我不确定，因为我个人不太清楚，我其实没有问过人们是否能够承担临床心理学家实习生的角色。我假设如果你是爱尔兰人，你就可以，因为如果你是爱尔兰人，你被允许在英国工作而无需工作许可证。这可能就符合了让你能够获得 NHS 薪酬的标准。是的。好的。是的。所以确实是这样。而且英国心理学会（BPS）也基本上表示，如果你获得了 PSI（爱尔兰心理学会）的资格，那么相互承认这些资格的申请过程非常顺利，双向都是如此。太棒了。他们理解。我们有陆地边界。人们一直开车往返。
the Psychological Society of Ireland, it's a really smooth application process to get those qualifications mutually recognised both ways. Great. They they understand. We have a land border. People drive up and down it all the time. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Thank you for illuminating that for us. Absolutely. Tell us a little bit about your early years. You were born in America.
是的，绝对的。谢谢你为我们阐明这一点。绝对的。跟我们讲讲你的早年生活吧。你出生在美国。
When did you move? When did you move over to Ireland? So I have only been here for six years now and so I was born and raised in America and sometimes people can't really tell from my accent but sometimes people when I say it they go oh yeah. You sound Irish to me rather than American. It's kind of in the middle, it's a bit embarrassing on both sides to be honest um so yeah born and raised in the United States um North Carolina is where I grew up which is in the south because that's confusing and then I went to college in Massachusetts at Mount Holyoke
你什么时候搬家的？你是什么时候搬到爱尔兰的？我到这里才六年，所以我是在美国出生长大的，有时人们从我的口音里听不出来，但有时当我说了之后，他们会说：“哦，是的。”你听起来对我说更像爱尔兰人，而不是美国人。有点在中间，说实话，两边都挺尴尬的。所以，是的，在美国出生长大，北卡罗来纳州是我长大的地方，也就是南方，因为这很让人混淆，然后我在马萨诸塞州的曼荷莲学院（Mount Holyoke College）上大学，
College and then I took a year to just kind of figure out what I wanted to do, really. I did corporate consulting, kind of found my feet for a little bit, realised that I was not fulfilled. So did you do psychology in college in America? So I did a double major. So I did anthropology and I did psychology. So a lot of my anthropological research was doing fieldwork, that of stuff i was in iceland for about three months um and then psychology i followed what would be a pretty standard psychological training program in the undergrad years um that being said so when i decided to come on over to ireland my wife had actually moved over to ireland for her doctorate and then went back to america met me we were together for a couple
然后我花了一年时间来弄清楚自己到底想做什么。我做过企业咨询，适应了一小段时间，意识到自己并没有获得成就感。所以你在美国的大学里学的是心理学吗？我修了双学位。我修了人类学，还修了心理学。我的很多人类学研究都是做实地考察，诸如此类的。我在冰岛待了大约三个月。至于心理学，我遵循了本科期间相当标准的心理学培训项目。话虽如此，当我决定来爱尔兰时，我妻子实际上为了她的博士学位搬到了爱尔兰，然后回到美国遇到了我，我们在一起呆了几年，然后我去了“我想去读研究生”，她说：“哦，你考虑过爱尔兰吗？那是我二十多岁时所有朋友都在的地方，让我们考虑一下。”当我申请硕士项目时，我申请了都柏林圣三一学院（Trinity College Dublin）、都柏林大学（University College Dublin）以及爱丁堡大学（University of Edinburgh）。显然后者不在爱尔兰，我只是真的很喜欢爱丁堡，我认为那是一个极好的城市。所以我申请了这些硕士项目。爱丁堡说：“没问题，我们非常欢迎你。”UCD 则说：“哦，你修的是双学位，这意味着你没有学过心理学。”我说：“哦，不，不，我实际上有两个文学士学位（BA），双学位就是这个意思，我有两个学士学位，我是同时修完两个学位的。”然后他们说：“哦，不，这说不通。”我接着问他们：“哦……我漏掉了任何特定的课程吗？”他们说：“哦，你必须去爱尔兰心理学会（PSI）看看这是否一样。”
of years and then I went oh I want to go to grad school and she was like oh have you thought about Ireland that's where all my friends in my 20s are let's let's think about it. When I applied for master's programs I applied to Trinity College Dublin and University College Dublin and to the University of Edinburgh um obviously that one's not in Ireland I just really like Edinburgh I think it's a fantastic city um so I applied to those Masters programs Edinburgh said yes absolutely we'd love to have you UCD went oh you have a double major that means that you didn't study psychology and I was like oh no no I actually I have two BAs that is what a double major means is I have I have two bachelors I did two at the
（接上文）你必须去爱尔兰心理学会看看这是否一样。所以我去了爱尔兰心理学会，我联系了他们，我说：“我这里漏掉了什么吗？因为我拥有心理学学士学位项目所列出的所有课程。”他们说：“嗯，因为你两者都修了，这跟只修一个是不同的。”这让你双倍优秀，不是吗？我要是看的话会这么觉得。你本来会这么想的。所以我当时非常困惑。不过圣三一学院对此没有任何问题。他们理解双学位的概念。圣三一学院有非常多的国际学生群体。所以我去那里读了硕士，然后当我申请心理咨询博士学位时，他们又让我回到 PSI，说：“但你真的
same time and then they went oh no no that doesn't make sense um so I then asked them I was like oh um am I missing any specific courses and they're like oh you have to go to the Psychological Society of Ireland to see if it's the same have to go to the Psychological Society of Ireland to see if it's the same. So I went to the Psychological Society of Ireland, I contacted them, and I was like, what am I missing here? Because I have all of the courses that are listed as what makes up a psychology bachelor's program. And they were like, well, because you did the both,
拿到了本科文凭吗？我们知道你拿到了硕士学位，但你拿到本科文凭了吗？”所以实际上，我当时认识爱尔兰心理学会的主席，在爱尔兰职业圈子里这又是一个非常小的世界，在很多方面这都很棒。找回你的人脉和方向非常容易。所以我刚好认识他，他说：“这完全没问题。
it's not the same as having done one. It makes you doubly good, doesn't it? That's how I would see that. You would think. So I was just very confused. Trinity had no issues with it, though. They understood kind of the double major thing. Trinity would have a very large international student population. So I went to do my master's there and then when I was applying to a doctorate in counselling psychology they then had me go back to the PSI and be like but is did you actually
当然，你拿到了学士学位。”不过他不得不给我写了一封信，基本上说明我的本科是算数的，然后我才能攻读博士学位。所以这实际上是一个关于不同国家拥有不同教育系统的故事。将美国的资格证书转到其他任何地方都非常棘手。将爱尔兰或英国的资格证书转到美国也非常棘手。这基本上不会发生，因为这是一个各州各异的情况。不过，由于我们在英国或爱尔兰完成了培训项目，
receive your undergrad we know you've got your master's but did you get your undergrad so I actually I knew the president of the Psychological Society of Ireland at the time um again very small world in Ireland professionally, which is great in many ways. It's very easy to find your people and to find your feet again. So I happened to know him and he was like, this is completely fine.
我们拥有更多灵活性。据我所知，对于这些心理学项目包含的内容，有更多的理解，所以我们可以相当轻松地去澳大利亚，也可以相当轻松地去英国，显然——如果在英语世界里，如果你实际上不是在美国接受培训，灵活性就会大得多，这非常奇怪。是的，我认为对我们来说也是一样的，我们可以相对容易地去新西兰或澳大利亚，但我认为基本上如果我去美国，我就得重新开始。就像，我认为这基本上就是它看起来的样子。所以在新冠疫情期间，我们家失去了亲人，我非常考虑回到美国，只是为了离家人更近。我联系了大约 10 个不同的州，只是说：“这是我的资历。
Of course, you've gotten your bachelor's. He had to write me a letter though, basically saying that my undergrad counted and then I was able to do the doctorate. So it's really a story of just different countries having different systems of education. It's very tricky to transfer qualifications from America anywhere else. It's very tricky to transfer qualifications from Ireland or the UK to America. It just doesn't really happen because it's a state-by-state situation because we've
我有本科，我有硕士，我有博士。这是我在这里的博士学位内容。这是它被认可的确切方式，所有这些东西。这是我的专业经验。这是我现在在做的。具备你对一个专业作品集的所有期望。”而且再次强调，我是你能达到的资格最高的人。然而其中一个州明确无误地告诉我，他们宁愿让我去读一个每年要花 7 万美元、为期六年的在线博士项目。这听起来真是响亮而清晰，不是吗？所以，尽管你的大学教育是在美国，你也是美国公民，假定我们现在拥有爱尔兰的双重国籍——还不太是，但很快就是了。是的，好的，嗯……是的，这太疯狂了，不是吗？就像“来再学六年，把这些钱都给我们，然后我们可能会让你……”在美国是各州而定的，这是人们常常不理解、不
completed our training programs in the UK or in Ireland though we have more flexibility there is more understanding to my to my understanding of what those psychology programs entail so we could go fairly easily to Australia we could go fairly easily to to obviously the UK like there's just more flexibility within the anglophone world if you're not actually training in America which is very odd yeah I think the same is true for us so we could go to New Zealand or Australia relatively easily but I think basically if I went to America I'd have to start again like I think basically if I went to America, I'd have to start again. Like, I think that's I think that's generally sort of what it would look like. So during Covid, we suffered a bereavement in the family and I very much considered going back to America just to be closer to family. I contacted around 10 different states and just being like, here's what my qualifications are.
认识到的事情。我可能恰好闯入了一个特别严格的州。他们也不接受任何电子交付的文件，他们说我必须带上所有的纸质格式。所以，哦，哇，也许这只是一个非常棘手的州，我们拭目以待。有两个州看起来稍微更温和一些，对国际资格更包容，那是加利福尼亚州和纽约州，因为我的理论是，人们倾向于住在那些地方，那是弄潮儿所在的地方。我的朋友，或者说是如果你的伴侣从事金融，或者你的伴侣从事电影，或者你的伴侣从事科技，那正是他们会有工作机会的地方。当然，美国还有很多其他的工作机会，美国有很多工作机会，那很好。但一般来说，向沿海地区的国际流动会更多。太棒了。非常感谢。这是一场非常非常有帮助的讨论。这不是我们在播客中发现或讨论过的话题。你能跟我们讲讲你现在在私人诊所里都在忙些什么吗？
I have my undergrad, I have my master's, I have my doctorate. Here's what my doctorate was in here. Here's exactly how it was received, all that stuff. Here's my professional experience. Here's what I'm doing now. Everything that you would want from a professional portfolio. And again, I'm as terminally qualified as you can be. And I was told in no uncertain terms by one state in particular that they would prefer to have me do an online doctorate program that would cost me $70,000 a year for six years. us out loud and clear doesn't it so even though your your college education was America and you are an American citizen presumably we now with dual nationality for Ireland uh not quite yet but very soon yes okay all right um yeah like that's that's just wild isn't it like come and study for another six years and give us all this money then we might let you it's state by state in america and that's something that people don't often under don't don't
是的，完全可以。我在私人诊所工作，做私立实践大约有一年半了。我在 2022 年完成了我的资格认证，然后我休了关于我孩子的产假。我做过一段时间成人自闭症实践的评估工作，然后我开办了自己的私人诊所。所以现在我专门为那些打算成为父母的人或正在向父母身份过渡的人提供服务。我专门为那些正在接受生育治疗的人、酷儿家庭工作，老实话，为像我自己的家庭这样的人工作，因为我不知道还有多少其他心理学家拥有这种生活经验。话虽如此，我也为那些不是酷儿的、拥有这种生活经验的人工作。话虽如此，我也为那些不是酷儿或没有接受过生育治疗的人工作。当然，那些工作也很美好。但那确实是目前对我有最大意义的工作，即陪伴人们经历母职转变（matrescence）。通常情况下有时是这样的。我也在接待很多
recognize um that i just might have stumbled into a particularly stringent state they also did not accept any electronically delivered files they said that i would have to bring in um everything in paper format so oh wow maybe it was just a really tricky stage we'll see um there were two states that looked a little bit more um amenable to international qualifications and those were california and new york because my theory is that's where people would kind of live that's where the movers and the shakers are my friend well it's where it's where let's say if you have a partner who's in finance or let's say you have a partner who's involved in film or if you have a partner in tech like that's where they would have job opportunities and of course there are many job opportunities elsewhere america has many job
非孕育父母（non-gestational parents），这非常有趣，因为特别是针对非孕育母亲的研究太少了。关于这方面的研究非常少。也有相当多的爸爸来找我。研究通常表明，人们倾向于找女性从业者，爸爸们主动说“哦，这里有一位真正有非孕育父母经验的女性心理学家，哇”是非常罕见的。所以我做一对一的工作，而且我在休产假期间也推出了一项服务——说实话，我想回馈很多时间——所以我为新生儿父母开设每周完全免费的支持小组，
opportunities that's great. But there would be more international movement to kind of the coastal areas generally. Great. Thank you so much. That's a really, really helpful discussion. And it's not something we've discovered or discussed on the podcast before. Could you tell us a little bit about what you get up to now in your private practice? Yeah, absolutely. So I am working private practice and I've been doing private practice for about a year and a half now so I finished up my qualifications in 2022 and then I took maternity leave regarding my baby. I worked in assessment work with the adult autism practice
爱尔兰的人们，因为这在当地是买不到的。我为正在经历怀孕期或产后阶段的人们举办每月的研讨会。我试图填补我在医疗保健领域，特别是孕产妇心理健康保健领域中看到的空白。这些解决方案在我们的妇产医院里是存在的。我们的妇产医院被赋予了太多的需求，所以如果我能在私营部门提供解决方案并且免费提供，为什么不呢？嗯，做得好，听起来你在做令人难以置信的工作。这让我想到了对成为父母的有意识的连接，你知道，对许多许多人来说，这只是顺理成章发生的事情，但即使是这样，在你等待将你的小宝贝迎接到你的家庭中的那九个月里，或者当你面对这一切时，这依然是一件需要好好消化的大事。这是一件大事，它确实会改变生活。
for a little bit and then I opened up my own private practice so right now I specialize in working with people who are intending to become parents or people who are transitioning to parenthood so I work specifically with people who are accessing fertility treatment queer families honestly families that are like my own because I don't know of many other psychologists who have that lived experience and that being said I work with people who are not queer psychologists who have that lived experience. That being said, I work with people who are not queer or who have not accessed fertility treatment. And of course, that work is lovely as well. But that is really the work that is most meaningful to me at this moment, is working with people through matrescence. It typically is sometimes. I'm getting a lot of
我最近和某人讨论过，关于他们不想要家庭、不想成为父母这件事，人们也会发现这很难理解，尽管这根本不管他们的事。但有时人们为了那个不得不或考虑去接受心理咨询，仅仅是为了证实他们不这样做的选择。但我喜欢你所做的事情，那就是真正帮助人们为这个巨大的改变留出空间。所以我认为当人们非常年轻就生孩子时，我在临床工作中发现，他们自己其实还没有真正度过他们的青春。我最好的朋友会完全坦白地说，当她成为母亲时，她还没有当够年轻人。我想她大概 21 岁左右就生了儿子。有时人们处于这样一种状态：他们几乎错过了那种体验，因为他们没有经历过，而且他们并没有真正准备好停止那段旅程。所以，你知道，我认为从单身或处于稳定恋爱关系转变为父母是一个巨大的改变，这是一个巨大的改变。
non-gestational parents as well, which is really interesting to work with because there's so little research on non-gestational mothers in particular. There's very little on it. I have a fair few dads who are coming to me as well. The research generally indicates that people want to work with female practitioners and it's very rare for dads to go, oh, here's a female psychologist who actually has experience of being a non-gestational parent to a child wow so I do one-to-one work and I'm also launching during maternity leave I want to give a lot of my time back to be honest so I'm doing weekly support groups for parents of newborns completely free
我所看到的——我完全同意你的看法——我看到最多的是，这不是一个支持性的改变，人们对父母身份和家庭生活应该如何发展有着固定的剧本，而这些剧本取决于拥有一个支持性的家庭环境，取决于拥有环绕着你的、理解发生什么的亲友网络。但在这些友谊关系中也有巨大的转变。你的整个生活都变了，对你时间的需求变了，你的身体资源变了，你宝贵的睡眠变了，你滋养身体的方式可能也变了。你的运动需求可能在改变。所有这些真正支撑心理健康的要素都被颠覆了。所以这变得非常非常棘手。有许多人在母职转变领域和向父母身份过渡的领域工作。
of charge people in Ireland, because it's just, it's not available. I'm doing monthly workshops for people who are kind of going through pregnancy or the postnatal period. I'm trying to kind of fill in the gaps that I have seen in healthcare and in maternal mental healthcare in particular. Those solutions are there within our maternity hospitals. Our maternity hospitals have a lot of demands put on them and so if i can provide a solution in the private sector and have it be free why not um yeah well done to you sounds like you're doing incredible work and it made me think about really conscious connection to becoming a parent and you know for many many people it's something that just happens like that but even even if it does it's still a lot to get your head around um either during nine
在爱尔兰为人们免费提供，因为这根本无法获得。我正在为那些处于孕期或产后阶段的人们举办月度工作坊。我正试图填补我在医疗保健领域，特别是孕产妇心理保健领域看到的空白。这些解决方案在我们的妇产医院里是存在的。我们的妇产医院面临着巨大的需求，所以如果我能在私营部门提供解决方案并且免费提供，为什么不呢？嗯，做得好，听起来你在做不可思议的工作，这让我想到了对成为父母的真正有意识的连接，你知道，对许多许多人来说，这只是顺理成章的事情，但即使是这样，要接受它仍然需要做很多思想准备，无论是在九个
months or when you're waiting to welcome in your in your bundle of joy to your to your family it's a big deal and it it does change lives and um I was in discussion with someone recently about you know them not wanting a family not wanting to be a parent people can find that really tricky to get their heads around as well even though it's none of their business um but yeah like yeah sometimes people have to or consider accessing counselling for for that as well you know just to validate their their choice to not do that but I love the idea of what you're doing which is actually really helping people make space for this massive change so you know I think when people have children very young I find in the clinical work I do that they've
月期间，还是当你等待着迎接你的小宝贝来到你的家庭时，这是一件大事，它确实会改变生活，嗯，我最近和某人讨论过，关于他们不想要家庭，不想成为父母，人们可能也会觉得很难理解这一点，即使这根本不管他们的事，但有时人们可能不得不或考虑为此寻求咨询，你知道，只是为了证实他们不这样做的选择，但我喜欢你所做的事情的理念，它实际上真的在帮助人们为这种巨大的改变腾出空间，所以你知道，我认为当人们很年轻就生孩子时，我在我做的临床工作中发现他们
not really finished having their own youth themselves one of my best friends would fully say that she was not done being a young person when she was then a mother. I think she had her son at like 21 or something. Sometimes people become in a position where they almost miss that they haven't had that, you know, and they weren't really ready to stop that journey. And so, you know, I think it is a big change going from being either single or in a committed relationship and then becoming a parent it's it's a massive change and what I see I completely agree with you what I see so much is that it's not a supportive change um that people have these scripts for how parenthood and family life should go and those scripts hinge on having a
自己还没有真正过完青春期。我最好的朋友之一完全会说，当她成为母亲时，她还没有当够年轻人。我想她大概21岁左右就生了儿子。有时人们会处于这样一种境地，他们几乎会怀念他们没有经历过的那些，你知道，他们其实并没有准备好结束那段旅程。所以，你知道，我认为从单身或处于稳定的恋爱关系转变为父母是一个巨大的改变，这是一个翻天覆地的变化，我看到的，我完全同意你的看法，我看到很多情况是，这并不是一个充满支持的改变，人们对为人父母和家庭生活应该是什么样有着既定的剧本，而这些剧本取决于是否拥有一个
supportive family environment they hinge on having people around you and your friend network who understand what's going on but there's a huge shift in even those friendship connections um your whole life changes the demands on your time change your physical your physical resources change you're blessed sleep you might be nourishing your body differently. Your movement needs might be changing. All of those things that really underpin mental well-being get shaken up. So it gets really, really tricky. There are many people who are working in the matrescence space and in the transition to parenthood space.
支持性的家庭环境，取决于你身边是否有理解发生了什么的人和朋友网络，但即使是这些朋友关系也会发生巨大的转变，你的整个人生都变了，对你时间的要求变了，你的体力资源变了，你宝贵的睡眠变了，你滋养身体的方式可能也不同了。你的运动需求可能在改变。所有这些真正支撑心理健康的要素都被打破了。所以事情变得非常非常棘手。有很多人都在从事母育转型和向父母身份过渡的领域工作。
One thing that I feel really passionate about and I don't see a lot of people doing is including fertility and trying to conceive within that maternal mental health space because many people as they're accessing fertility treatment they will experience very high highs they will experience very low lows there's a loss there's trauma history inherent to it there's so much to reproductive trauma and fertility treatment would be considered clinically reproductive trauma even if fertility intervention is not experienced as capital t trauma it would be considered reproductive trauma generally um as with loss as with miscarriage as with all of these other things that so many people do experience on their pathways to becoming parents and that affect their parenting and their experience on their pathways to becoming parents and that affect
我非常热衷且发现很少有人在做的一件事，就是在孕产妇心理健康领域纳入生育和备孕支持。因为许多人在进行生育治疗时，会经历极高的情绪高涨和极低的情绪低落。其中存在失落感，并且固有地伴随着创伤历史。生殖创伤包含的内容太多了，生育治疗在临床上通常会被视为生殖创伤，即使生育干预没有被体验为大写的“创伤”，它一般也会被视为生殖创伤。正如伴随而来的失落、流产，以及许许多多人在成为父母的道路上确实经历过、并且会影响他们的为人父母之道以及相关体验的其他所有事情。
their parenting and their experience with their family. That being said, there is not readily available mental health care support for people going through fertility treatment or trying to conceive. It's only really when people conceive that all of a sudden there's this, oh, you're in a maternity hospital. Oh, there's a lovely paralegal mental health team that's here to support you. I just don't see the fertility support being there as needed. And that's changing. That is changing. It's available in some private clinics,
以及他们作为家庭成员的体验。话虽如此，对于正在经历生育治疗或备孕的人来说，并没有现成的心理健康护理支持。只有当人们真正怀孕时，突然之间才会听到：“哦，你在妇产医院。哦，这里有一个可爱的围产期心理健康团队来支持你。”我只是觉得，并没有按需提供生育支持。这种情况正在改变。确实在改变。一些私立诊所已经提供了这种支持，
but it's not necessarily offered to every couple. But I would argue that every couple should be getting fairly regular support if they're going through fertility treatment yeah it was only I think recently I'm 42 currently it was only on your recent social media post I'm sure it was you that I learned of the word matrescence it was not something I had heard of it was not something I had heard of. It was not something I could spell. Could you, A, spell it for our audience and, B, tell us what it is? Absolutely. So M-A-T-R-E-S-C-E-N-C-E. So it's adolescence, which is the transition to adulthood, right? It's like that.
但并非一定会提供给每一对夫妇。不过我认为，如果夫妇正在经历生育治疗，每一对夫妇都应该得到相当规律的支持。是的，我想是不久前——我目前42岁——我是在你最近的一篇社交媒体帖子上，确信就是你，我才知道了“母性蜕变”（matrescence）这个词。这不是我以前听过的词。这不是我听过的词。这不是我能拼写出来的词。A，你能为我们的听众拼写一下吗？B，能告诉我们它是什么意思吗？当然可以。是 M-A-T-R-E-N-C-E。就像“青春期”（adolescence），也就是向成年期过渡，对吧？就像那样。
Matrescence is the transition to motherhood um it basically is a word that encapsulates the massive hormonal physical lifestyle shifts that you're experiencing as you transition to having children um typically it is only targeted at mums and mums who were pregnant because it does consider hormonal shifts it does consider physical shifts in terms of the postnatal body and all the identity changes that might come with that and the body image concerns that many people have postnatally there isn't really a word for patrescence there isn't really a word no patrescence no there is essence but i mean so there's so little space in my opinion for men to come
“母性蜕变”是向母亲身份过渡的过程。它基本上是一个概括了你在转变为母亲的过程中所经历的巨大荷尔蒙、身体和生活方式转变的词。通常，它只针对母亲以及怀孕的母亲，因为它确实考虑了荷尔蒙的变化，考虑了产后身体方面的身体变化以及随之而来的所有身份转变，还有许多人对产后身体形象的担忧。其实并没有一个词来形容“父性蜕变”，真的没有一个词。没有父性蜕变吗？有“本质”（essence），但我的意思是……在我看来，留给男性聚在一起并分享父亲身份体验的空间太少了。
together and share experiences of fatherhood um it's it's very limited in social media um and that's because a lot of the default labor goes to women generally and to mothers um so there's very little uh available for presence I have no idea what the word would be for a general gender neutral essence for people who are turning into parenthesis. Maybe you should coin it. Maybe that should be your thing. If people are interested in learning more about you
它在社交媒体上非常有限，这是因为许多默认的劳动通常都落在了女性和母亲身上。因此，几乎没有什么可用于“父性蜕变”的资源。我完全不知道对于那些即将成为父母的人来说，一个通用的、无性别的“蜕变”会是什么词。也许你应该创造一个。也许这应该成为你的招牌。如果人们有兴趣更多地了解你，
and whether you do ever coin that term, where can they find you on socials, Laura? So I'm at the dental psychologist on Instagram um that is where I kind of do everything I have not downloaded TikTok I think I'm too old to do it but the dental psychologist is where I am I'm also on LinkedIn under my name which is very unique um thank you to my mother for that branding and for the impossible name um but that's okay say it say it once more for us say your beautiful name because I've I fluffed it up at least four times in a row when we were doing the intro
以及你是否真的创造了那个词，他们在社交媒体上哪里可以找到你呢，劳拉？我在Instagram上的账号是“the dental psychologist”（牙科心理学家）。我基本上是在那里做所有事情。我没有下载TikTok，我想我年纪太大了，做不来这个。但我主要活跃在“the dental psychologist”。我在领英上也有账号，用的就是我的本名，这个名字非常独特。感谢我母亲给我的这个品牌定位和这个不可能念对的名字。没关系，再为我们说一次。说出你美丽的名字，因为我们在做开场白时，我连续至少四次把它搞砸了。
it's Dr Leora Deflumery um yeah Deflumery it sounds like a sneeze but that's okay I will make sure that I link to all of this beautiful content and advice in my show notes. But before we finish, have you got your best piece of advice for aspiring psychologists to reduce burnout on their way to where they're getting to? Know why you want to do it and know what program you want to do. And I often have people come to me through a lot of like linkedin messages actually which is interesting um i have people come to me saying why did you do a counseling psychology doctoral program for me the counseling modality was so radical and so impactful that it really kept me going through the application process. I love that counselling psychology is about putting people in their context
我是里奥拉·德弗勒里博士（Dr Leora Deflumery）。是的，Deflumery听起来像是一个喷嚏，但没关系。我一定会确保在我的节目介绍里链接所有这些精彩的内容和建议。但在我们结束之前，你对立志成为心理学家的人有什么最好的建议，以减少他们在实现目标的道路上的职业倦怠吗？明确你为什么要这样做，并明确你想攻读什么项目。我经常通过领英私信收到很多人的咨询，这很有趣。有人来问我：“你为什么选择攻读咨询心理学博士项目？”对我而言，咨询疗法具有如此彻底的变革性和影响力，以至于它真正支撑我走过了整个申请过程。我非常喜欢这一点，咨询心理学在于将人们置于他们的语境之中，
and that it has an activism component to it, that it has this understanding of the systemic factors that underpin mental health concerns. I absolutely love it. I find it so deeply feminist in its approach, while also obviously being incredibly evidence-based I love it I don't know that I would have been able to go through what I see so many people going through of those years of applying to doctoral programs for some people if it wasn't a program that I went oh my
并且它具有行动主义的成分，它理解构成心理健康问题基础的系统性因素。我绝对太喜欢它了。我发现它的方法具有深刻的女权主义色彩，同时显然也具有极强的循证基础。我太喜欢了。我不知道自己是否能经历我看到那么多人正在经历的那些年复一年申请博士项目的事情——对于某些人来说——如果这不是一个让我发出“天哪，我在其中看到了我的一切”感叹的项目的话。
god I can see everything of myself in it um write about why you want to do it. Write about why you want to do a doctoral program and not a psychotherapy program. Understand why you don't want to be a social worker, but why you want to be a psychologist. Understand what the doctoral part gives you. Do you want to do assessment work? Do you want to do research work? Do you want to do writing? Understand what all of it is because without that you'll be sitting there going why didn't I do the minimum in order to work therapeutically with people that's a long road yeah yeah it is thank you so much for your time and for sharing your beautiful compassion with us so so generously it's been a real delight speaking to you and wishing you the
写下你为什么要这样做。写下你为什么要攻读博士项目，而不是心理治疗项目。明白你为什么不想成为一名社会工作者，而是想成为一名心理学家。明白博士学位能为你带来什么。你想做评估工作吗？你想做研究工作吗？你想从事写作吗？明白这一切究竟是什么，因为如果没有这些，你就会坐在那里想：“我当初为什么不做最低限度的事情来和人们进行治疗工作呢？”那是一条漫长的路。是的，是的，确实如此。非常感谢你抽出时间，如此慷慨地与我们分享你美丽的同情心。与你交谈真的是一件非常愉快的事，并祝愿你
very best of luck with everything that comes for you next as you become a family of four very soon too yes we have a baby incoming next week yep thank you so much um it's been absolutely lovely speaking to you and I look forward to continuing to see what you're up to this platform is so needed and I will absolutely be sharing it around Ireland as well. Oh, thank you so much. That's really kind of you. It's really lovely to meet you. Do stay in touch.
接下来成为一个四口之家的一切都顺顺利利。是的，我们下周就要迎来一个宝宝了。耶！非常感谢你。与你交谈绝对是非常愉快的一段时光，我期待着继续关注你的近况。这个平台是如此被需要，我也绝对会在爱尔兰各地分享它。噢，非常太感谢了。你真是太好了。很高兴认识你。保持联系。
Absolutely. I will do. All right. Bye bye bye, Marianne. What an absolute pleasure it was to speak to Dr. Leora. I hope that you found it a really interesting listen as well. Please do go and follow her as the gentle psychologist on Instagram, post some lovely content. So, you know, there's lots to continue
当然，我会的。好的，再见，再见，玛丽安。与里奥拉博士交谈真是一件绝对愉快的事。我希望你也会觉得这是一次非常有趣的聆听。请务必去Instagram上关注她，作为“the gentle psychologist”，她发布了很多精彩的内容。所以，你知道的，那里还有很多东西需要继续去了解和欣赏。
to learn and appreciate there too. I think if I was an aspiring psychologist and I was footloose and fancy free, I loved Ireland when I was there in Galway. I might well have considered going and training there as either a clinical or a counselling psychologist if they would have had me especially now that we learn that it is actually a paid opportunity now in in Ireland for counselling psychology so maybe this gives us hope that there is change possible counselling psychology in the UK. Have you got any ideas for a podcast episode that you think would be really interesting, please do get in contact with me. Please do pitch it to me. I will look forward to bringing the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which you can access usually about 10am on Saturdays on
我想，如果我是一个有志于成为心理学家的人，而且无拘无束、自由自在，当我以前在戈尔韦时，我是那么喜欢爱尔兰。如果他们愿意收留我的话，我很有可能会考虑去那里接受临床或咨询心理学培训，特别是现在我们得知，在爱尔兰，咨询心理学实际上是一个带薪的学习机会。所以也许这给了我们希望，即英国的咨询心理学也有可能发生改变。如果你对你认为会非常有趣的播客单集有什么想法，请务必与我联系。请向我推介。我期待着为您带来下一期的《Aspiring Psychologist Podcast》（有志心理学家播客），你通常可以在周六上午10点左右在
YouTube, with each brand new mp3 version being available from 6am on Mondays. Take care. Thank you so much for being part of my world. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit
YouTube上收听，每个全新的mp3版本从周一早上6点开始提供。保重。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。这是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》。我叫亚娜，是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集锦》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现它关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。它让我惊叹于通往那里的路线竟然有这么多，而且没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满了信心：不，我没有做错，并且减轻了对自己的压力。所以如果你觉得有点
uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对成为临床心理学家感到心神不定，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会把它放下了。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。